I now have my uh live deployment here
and I can continue to dashboard and I've
got my project
one out of five things for the
production checklist.
Is that all? Were you able to get that?
>> Cool.
>> So, we're going to jump over to the
repository on GitHub that clicking that
big repo button. And then I'm going I'm
going to quit out of Slack and all these
things. And I'm going to jump into a
terminal. Head over to a directory that
I'm happy with that I'm happy to pop
this in. And I'm going to get clone
that. Oops, that's not it. I need to
copy it, obviously. Click the big green
code button. Copy the clone and get
clone AIE London demo.
Awesome. I'm going to jump into
that uh
that repo there. And then if we jump
back to the doc site, this is at by the
way this site is if you go nicapp.comie
and then that will redirect you here.
Um, if you don't have the Verscell CLI
installed, you can install it with
so you can install that with mpmi-g
Verscell.
Uh, that will probably take you to a
Verscell login first time you use it.
Uh, which will pop up this um this sign
up process that you can allow and then
you should be signed in. And you can
check that with versel. Who am I?
Yes.
Good thing is that in a small room like
this, the Wi-Fi shouldn't be an issue.
>> Were you able to log in?
>> Cool.
>> Yep.
>> Perfect.
the our IM team is doing awesome work
with the Versel CLI. Um I'm a big fan. I
am biased, but I am a big fan. Uh so
once we are all set up, logged in, we go
into our repository that we just cloned
and we run Verscell link. Uh we say yes,
should be able to find it if you have
the same name. Uh, and then we want to
pull down our environment variables. And
that should give us the, which I
probably shouldn't show, um, but it gets
invalidated. That should give us an OIDC
token which we'll be using to
authenticate with both the AI gateway
for our inference and for self sandbox
which is
yeah we we get that a lot as well where
internally you can imagine we have a ton
of teams I think I'm on like seven or
eight different like versel teams and so
authenticating with the right one can be
um or finding the projects can sometimes
be challenged, but making it easier
every single time.
>> Yeah, you may have already had a token
in there from
>> a work one.
Nice.
Oh, of the vers CLI.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah, that is if you have if
it's installed with
uh with npm, you can do npm install-g
uh versel at latest and that should get
you on to the latest one. I had that
recently as well because we just
invalidated the old authentication
method in favor of a new one.
You can also look which versel and that
should tell you what what you installed
it with.
See mine is with pmpm instead of npm
which that classic frustrating problem
of which package manager owns this which
for
Were
you able to set things up? Yeah.
I love your shirt, by the way.
>> Homemade.
>> It looks It looks very professional.
>> For those watching, it's Typescript
shirt. It's very cool. Typescript till I
die. Ding that hill.
Is it getting set up or it's installing
new?
>> Great.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is the versel link.
By the way, if you haven't seen, we did
ship a new landing page. Finally, after
two years, we replaced my terrible
landing page. Um, which this was
definitely not done by me. This is
design engineers on our team. Very, very
cool. Um, live download figures.
I love showing this work because it's
looks so good.
Oh, and if you didn't know, if you've
used Open Code, Open Code is all built
on AI SDK as well. And this is the most
DAX quote ever.
Open code uses AI SDK. Uh, all right.
We all set up.
>> Cool.
>> So, we're good to go. So, first thing
we're going to run is uh pmppm install
or npm install. Uh if you're using npm
in 2026, maybe maybe use pmpp or bun. I
love bun. Uh and then we can just check
that it is working. This is a fresh xjs
app, so we shouldn't have any issues.
But if you run the dev server and then
head to localhost 3000, you should see
the wonderful um pretty new actually
starting screen.
>> Is that all set up for everyone?
>> Yes.
>> Amazing.
>> Uh so we're going to start with our
agent. We are going to build an agent.
First thing we're going to have to do is
install a few dependencies because we
are working with JavaScript, right? We
love installing dependencies. So, we're
going to jump into the terminal and
we're going to run pmppm add AI at AISDK
react and uh ZOD. Don't worry, we're
right at the beginning so you're not
missing anything.
Um,
so we are, if you want to follow along
with your computer, um, I should write
it. Is there like a whiteboard or
something? No, there isn't. Um the this
site that we're on is niko
albbanaz.comie.
Um and that will get you to the project
setup which you can follow right here.
And then we're just on we're literally
just starting off with building out the
agent. Um
so uh first thing we're doing I was
saying we are building with JavaScript.
So we got to install some dependencies.
Uh we are going to be installing the AI
SDK which is this very nice uh twoline
npm package right here. Um our react
adapter which we'll see in a little bit
and zod which we'll be using for
defining a few um a few schemas that
we'll be using later on in the project.
So last time I did an AIE workshop was
in AISDK 4 and back then everything was
built along pretty much four primitives
which were generate text stream text
generate object stream object those
still exist although we've kind of
pushed as much into the the text
generation functions as possible. So you
can now do structured outputs with just
those generate text and stream text. Um,
but we've also been working on providing
a more objectoriented approach to
building agents with the SDK. And part
of that was like we saw in our own
applications how much they were
ballooning by having all of the LLM
logic in the call site. So you had your
API chat.ts and X.js route handler and
in there you had 2,000 lines of code
because you had the tools defined in
line and you had the system prompt
defined in line. And so um part of the
the beauty of the AISDK is it is
lightweight JavaScript. And so you can
define this once in code in a monor repo
and then use it anywhere whether it's a
next.js app, it's a it's a simple bun
server, whatever it is, it's plain
JavaScript. Um and so this was our like
first foray I would say into that which
is what we call a toloop agent. Now um
we have the mastermind behind the AI SDK
is German. Uh and so naming is something
we uh we hold quite dearly. Uh this is
one of our shorter APIs but we find that
this is quite obvious as to what it
does. It is a tool loop using agent. Um
kind of does what it says on the tin. Uh
so to build our first agent, all we need
to do is define this import this tool
loop agent um and then specify a model.
So we're going to do this. We're going
to create a new file called um agent.ts
in a lib folder. And I'm actually going
to open this up in an editor so it's a
little easier for me. And I'm going to
bump up the
font so everyone can see.
Let's do
Is that better? Can we read? Yeah. Cool.
Um, so we're going to head into the app.
Actually, we can do it in the top level
and we're going to create a new file and
it's going to be in a lib folder and
it's going to be called agent.ts.
Now in here we'll copy this snippet and
like I said before we're importing to
loop agent uh specifying our model. Uh
the cool thing here uh if you've used
the AISDK before you may have seen this
syntax where you uh import a provider.
So you'd import open aai from AIS if I
can type at AISDKAI
and then you could specify this would
create a model provider instance that
you could then specify a um model ID in
here. One of the cool things that we
ship with uh in AI SDK 6 is the concept
of a global provider which allows you to
effectively attach a provider to every
single um AISDK function that you have
in your application and by default that
is the AI gateway and so by specifying
just plain strings you can access any
model in the AI gateway. If you want you
can override this and use any provider
as that global provider here. Um, but
this just makes it really easy to get
started. So, uh, we are going to be
using, what did we say? GPT54 mini.
Always hope to keep these kind of things
up to date. I did this last night, so
this is pretty up to date. Uh, but
probably when this video goes out, this
will not be. Um, this model will give us
I haven't used 54 mini a lot. I've used
54 a ton. Um, but this gives us a nice
way of kind of cheap and fast way to
experiment with our agent as we go. So
this is our agent definition. Kind of
surprising how how little it is, but it
literally is just this reusable agent
using GPT5 for mini. Um we're then going
to have to create a way to call our
model and we're going to do that by
building a route handler. So that's
going to be in a folder called API which
has a folder called chat. And then in
there with NexJS's conventions, we can
define a post handler in a route.ts ts
file.
Uh so again, that's a app API chat
route.ts.
And so one of the cool things uh going
back to why you might want to use this
instead of just stream text out of the
box is that this allowed us to keep all
of our agent definition in one place
while having just the concerns for
streaming from that agent in another
place. And we've abstracted a lot of the
complexities for that streaming into
really that one line of code, this
create agent UI stream response. Again,
if you've used um the AI SDK before,
what's happening here is literally the
same as uh con result equals stream
text. You have your stream text call and
then you return result.2 UI message
stream um response.
Uh so it's effectively the same thing.
Um, and on your agent, you also have my
agent.stream,
which is your agent's streaming
function.
Um, so that gives us our way of, and I'm
going to get rid of this. Uh, that gives
us our way of actually calling our
agent. You can see that our post handler
is taking in some messages and just
passing that in alongside our agent. And
now we need to actually create a a page
um and a client to call that uh that
agent or call that endpoint. So we can
head to our page.tsx our homepage and
replace it with the text that's here.
And what we've got here is uh the
infamous now use chat hook which was
actually the first component of the SDK
when we launched whatever three three
years ago. Um, and this is managing all
of our message state and then helping us
send those messages off to our route
handler. So we have we dstructure
messages which will be our message
store. It will all be on the client
today. Um, error and the send message
function. uh we check if there's an
error and then otherwise in our markup
in the UI we will map through the
messages in our message state and then
for each message we will map through the
parts uh and we can have you used the AI
SDK before is this first okay so and and
you have as well so um or you haven't
this is the first time seeing okay great
so most of you guys have seen this so I
can fly through this um but yeah this is
how we're rendering on the client so we
can now run pmpp rundev
and we should now think I we should now
be able to say hi and get back our
response. So we've got our our chatbot
or our agent as we should say it's 2026
uh ready ready to go. Now the first and
most basic thing that we'll be wanting
to update our agent is to change its
behavior. One like very core way of
doing that is altering its system prompt
or its instructions and you can do that
with the AI SDK in your agent definition
by passing in an instructions
uh parameter. So you can do that here. I
can say respond like a cowboy. Um and
now when I go back to our agent and I
say hi, we should see howdy partner. How
can I help you today? with a nice cowboy
emoji as well. Um,
so this goes back to I mentioned to
Casper right at the beginning. Uh, what
I wanted to do today is try and
communicate uh what I believe to be the
core building blocks for building agents
in 2026 which are an agent runtime uh
being a way to build your your harness
effectively. So how do you manage the
loop? How do you manage context between
the loop? That kind of thing. uh the
tools itself that you're passing into
that runtime. And then finally, a
computer uh or some kind of sandbox file
system for the agent to be able to
persist state or execute code uh within
within its run. Uh we'll call the runs
being the work the sessions that it's
working on. And so uh this is like one
of building blocks, the instructions. I
think a lot of folks kind of scoffed
their head at system prompt being
something of 2023 when we were first
really starting, but we'll see today how
we're going to use the instructions
alongside those two other comp really
like get the most out of an agent and
really uh influence its behavior. Um
so that's the starting point. That's
we've built our basic agent here. uh
we're going to do the first thing that I
think a lot of folks will want to do is
give the agent the ability to pull in
more context in some kind of way. Uh
basic thing that we can do today because
we don't have a great use case is just
bring in web search. Uh so the way that
we can do that is we're going to jump
back to the terminal. Uh I'm going to
stop my dev server here and I'm going to
run this pmppm add AI SDK OpenAI.
And the reason we're going to add the
OpenAI provider uh is to be able to get
the tool definition for something that's
called a provider tool. Now there are
roughly three types of tools. There are
custom tools and I can actually find
this uh right here because this is a
good help for me. Um so there are three
types of tools. You've got custom tools
which are tools that you define
yourself. Uh you provide a description,
you provide an input schema and you
provide an execute function. This is
effectively giving the agent the ability
to run any kind of arbitrary function
that you want to give it based on the
context of the conversation. Uh we then
have provider defined tools. These are
quite interesting. These are tools that
an LLM provider will usually postrain
their models to use effectively. So,
Anthropic has like a bash tool which
alongside all that cloud code usage that
is subsidized uh they're training to use
a lot better. Um they also have uh a
tool for computer use as well. And so
the idea here that you define what the
agent should do when it calls it, but
they've worked really hard on the
description and the input schema to make
sure that the agent is very effective at
calling it. The final type is uh
provider executed and these are tools
that the that exist in the LLM
provider's infrastructure. And so uh the
classic example of this is web search
web search tool. Anthropic has a web
search tool as well. You don't actually
provide the tool or the what should
happen when the tool is called but you
kind of opt yourself into the LM
provider being able to use it. And if
the agent decides to use it, they will
literally execute that on their server
and add the tool result to the message
state and return all of that back to
you. So the really nice thing about it
is that we don't have to write any more
code like you get it out of the box. The
bad thing about these provider executed
tools is you're obviously tied to a a
single provider. But for today, for this
demo, uh not so much of an issue and
allows us to move quite quickly. Uh, and
so what's happening when we when we
import the OpenAI provider here is that
we're literally just using this to
augment our request that's going off to
OpenAI ultimately to include that opt-in
flag like I want the web search tool
included. Um,
so we will add that into our definition,
our agent definition. And you'll see we
remove our instructions as well. And
actually that is literally it for us to
well I need to run the dev server as
well ppm rundev but I can now jump back
to my agent here and say like when is
AIE London AI engineer summit London I
think that's what this is called and
we'll see a long pause terrible UI but
eventually we should see our response
come back in here our augmented contacts
are rag bot, if you will, using the old
archaic language. Um, but our agent now
has the ability to fetch in and pull in
relevant context uh via web search. And
there's some cool things that we can do
here. Uh, if you pass in an object into
this um into this tool
uh what is this like factory function
here, you can actually specify things
like the user location here. And so you
can say type I just use the uh language
server to kind of help me here. But I
can say that we're in London.
Uh and that allows you to maybe get like
uh when is AI engineer summit? So we
don't include London and in theory we'll
get more London oriented. Yeah, there
you go. So like that extra context or
those parameters are now being passed
into OpenAI in into the request that's
going off to open AAI ultimately.
Uh so cool we've got a way now of
augmenting our context and we've
provided our agent with its first tool.
Um but the problem that we have if we
show this again uh when is AI engineer
summit you guys already saw this. Uh I
think what did I do? When is AI
is that there is nothing showing up in
the UI right now. Uh so user has no idea
what's going on and uh well the agent is
actually going through multiple steps
there and calling a tool. So what we
really want to do is actually render in
our markup in this uh
page.tsx.
We want to render for different uh we
want to render what should we want to
describe what should be rendered in the
UI when different tools are being used
specifically when our tool web search.
Uh so we could go in here and we could
say case and then the AI SDK follows
this convention of uh you a prefix of
tool and then you would specify your
tool name. So we'd go and we'd go to our
agent and we see it's called web search.
So we'd say tool web search and then we
define some kind of markup here
like uh let's see say like div
web search.
My god I'm typing I haven't typed in
months. Uh and you can see now that our
agent has called web search. Um but this
process is terrible. Like what if we
wanted to see like what is the p like
input? There's probably a query here
that's going in but it's typed as
unknown. That's ugly. We don't want to
do that. Um so this is where I'm going
to delete all of that. That's why typed
it and it's not on the page. This is
where we are going to leverage another
really awesome component of the AI SDK
which is the endtoend type system that
we've built. Um, so the big assumption
goes through every single AI SDK API
decision is like we want to have the
agent definition being the source of
truth that everything kind of inherits
from and deres from. So we spend a lot
of time across tool calls across the UI
library making sure that it can flow
nicely. Uh, and so where we start where
we have to start with that is the atomic
unit of state in our application which
is the message. Um, and so we can get a
typed message by using this type helper
infer agent UI message. Uh, so we're
going to jump back into our agent
definition and pass in the type of our
agent. Now this agent UI message is
fully type- safe based on the tools that
we pass. Um, and so we can now if we
head to the route handler, we can update
the route handler to show that the to
define that the messages coming in are
of our custom UI message type. But most
importantly now we can go back into the
page and we can type use chat as having
my agent UI message.
And so what you'll notice uh once you've
done that and that's imported from our
lib agent file. So when we scroll back
down and we check for the different part
types, we'll see that we should have our
web search tool here now. And if you
were to go in here and check for the um
the input and output types, you'll see
that they are typed, which is very cool.
So, I'm not going to bore you with
trying to type out and build a component
on the spot because I can't design at
all. Um, and I don't think any of us
design anything really by hand anymore.
But you'll see if we jump back, we now
have a nice component in line for our
web search. And we can try that out
again and say who is Nico Alanz. Sorry,
kind of egoistic. But, um, now you can
see our component has that pending
state, which is really cool in line. Uh
so what do we have next? That's
augmented our context. Now on to like
what I think is the most interesting
component also in 2026 which is
providing our agent with a computer with
a sandbox to interact with. Um, and to
kind of take a second here, we saw
this really take off where internally we
have an agent called DZero, which has
access to all of our like the chat with
your data that we're talking about has
access to pretty much all of the versel
back backend, our entire admin panel,
all of Salesforce, all of these kind of
things. Uh, and the idea here was I
think it was our head of data who wanted
was was destroyed from getting tagged in
everything and he wanted naturally a
replacement Slackbot that could do all
of that um, and help scale his team as
well. And there was a really interesting
point where it went from let's have all
of this this agent that has all of these
tools and it would use maybe five or 10
of them at a time and return an answer
that was kind of somewhat hallucinated
to when he added a file system to it and
some instructions there to say okay
every single piece of work every session
that you do you have like a scratch pad
in the file system which is where You're
storing like an initial plan that
becomes your reference for exactly what
you should be doing in each step and
then you have a directory that's for
your research and you collect everything
in there. And there were two things that
were happening there. For one, like the
agent started f like actually following
through and going through entire tasks
because
things weren't just being layered in
this insanely long context window where
the initial thing was getting was
getting thrown away. like the the
instructions there were create this plan
file and in that plan file was the
objective right at the top and then
right below the instructions were follow
this plan file to a te check things off
as you go and all of a sudden now you
have this fascinating thing where the
agent is reading and pulling in and
reminding itself
step okay this is my objective and so
it's staying on track more and at the
end you get this really great artifact
that shows exactly what the agent did
what work went into it. Uh and so it was
kind of this emergent behavior that we
saw where they were actually very good
pairing this file system whether it was
a full computer or just a virtual file
system worked very very well. Um so
we've now seen it across pretty much
every agent that we build internally.
We've got an agent for the GTM team. Uh
we've got an agent like I said the data
one. Um, we have a customer support one
that pushed our customer support tickets
down by like 90% with I think a 95% like
they're people that were actually saying
thank you, thank you, which we we
haven't really seen before. All of these
are backed and underpinned by this kind
of file systembacked
agent approach. And so that's what I
wanted to show off today. Um, we are
going to be using a Verscell product for
this Versel sandbox and I have built a
lot with different sandboxes over the
years. And there's something really cool
that is just shipping now that's in beta
which is called um named sandboxes,
persistent sandboxes, and I think I have
them up right here. Uh, and that's what
we're going to be taking advantage of
today. So one of the uh issues that you
have with sandboxes in general is that
unless you're using it on your computer,
they are fundamentally ephemeral, right?
Like whether a provider has a a sandbox
that can live for 30 days or five hours,
at the end it's done. Um and so we were
thinking about how we could work around
those challenges. And what the team
ended up coming up from is this really
cool concept of like every sandbox has a
name and then every sandbox can have
sessions and sessions are just instances
of that underlying like sandbox item we
can call it. Um, and every time you in
your product or in your code want to use
a sandbox, you reference it by its name
and under the scenes, Verscell will
either see if there is an active
instance for that session and route you
to that or it will spin up a new one
optimistically and route you to that. So
in your code, you simplify all of this
life cycle management of is my computer
running, which one should I point to?
I've written we'll show if I have time
at the end something I've been working
on that I built out an entire like life
cycle management system where I was
literally like uh taring the entire file
system after every single request and
then storing in blob and then like
spinning up new it was terrible and this
is just so much easier. So where we'll
be getting to today is almost this kind
of like I hate to drop the open claw
thing but like we will have be able to
have this specific computer that we'll
be able to reference throughout every
single request. Um and behind the scenes
what will be happening is that Verscell
will actually spin it down after a
timeout after inactivity but it will
snapshot the file system. So the state
remains the same and when you make
subsequent requests it will spin up a
new one with that snapshotted state. So
it's effectively feels like the exact
same machine which is really cool. Um so
this is in beta right now. Uh but I'm
already using it a ton and it's working
really really well and we've got a lot
more that's coming here. So the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to jump. By the way, any questions
so far?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, great. Um, so the question because
I don't know if the mic picks it up is
like do you you're saying for every
agent request do you send the entire
history?
>> I think that's the default
>> with use chat. Yes. So that is the
default um is right here. When we make
every single request with send message,
this is going to send the entire this is
going to take the entire message history
in the route and send that over to your
agent. Um, now you'll always want to
send or
that's a bold claim. Uh, you will your
your message history is your context,
right? Going into to into this into your
agent. And so that will always want to
be something
bigger, right? Like as much of your
conversation history as you would like,
but sending over the wire all of those
messages every single time is not really
something that you'll do. And so the the
more classic pattern is sending just the
most recent message here. And you can do
that in your client with
uh prepare. I think it's in the
I don't write code anymore so I can't
remember what the name is. Uh it's
probably on the transport which is new.
And then we have uh in here where is it?
Oh, we're not importing anything from AI
from AI. Uh I'll just show you very
quickly. Actually, you know what I
should be doing is just show you in the
docs. That's even better. Don't know why
I'm trying to type this all out. Um,
basically what we will do here is you
can specify to just send the most recent
message and then you fetch the all of
the messages on the server in your
endpoint and you put those together and
send those to the model. But where I
think you're where you're leaning is
more around like the context thing,
right? You don't want to send
old irrelevant things to the model,
>> right? like the context engineering side
of things of like pruning stuff and and
making things go away. Is that where
you're going or
>> Yeah. Um so that's where things get
harder to do uh more from a
they're they're simple to do with the
SDK, but it it requires tradeoffs um and
it requires decisions from the developer
that we don't necessarily impose from
the framework. So we have a few
approaches that you can do here. They're
all based on using or most of them are
based on using uh two things. For one,
in um behind the scenes, what's
happening in our endpoint here is that
we're actually taking our UI messages,
these messages, and we use uh a function
under the hood called convert to model
messages, which strip away a lot of the
UI
um specific like timestamps, ids, and
all that kind of stuff. Um but under the
hood as well you can define this I
believe to like
ignore certain things convert data parts
to different structures to alter your
context that's coming in. Um so in
general like you own the messages that
are coming in. So if you wanted to
messages mapap and like go through and
say uh if m do if message roll is I
don't know uh assistant and uh
m.artsinccludes
what is it like if there's a tool call
this with the typing starts getting fun.
What is the type here? Basically, you
can go through and and and define it
like I want to strip out this type of
tool call. You can totally do that. Um
the the way that we see
bigger code bases doing uh is actually
using a function that we have called
prepare step. And this runs before if we
think about everything that was
happening in our previous web search. is
like agent, we send a message that spins
up a new assistant message. In the first
step of that assistant message, it
called web search and then it sent back
it basically the agent runtime took all
of that context and then decided what to
do next. And it could have used web
search again, could have used the
computer, whatever it might be, but each
of those are like individual steps. And
with the AI SDK, you can listen in. you
have this callback for that runs before
every single step and then this allows
you to modify any of the parameters
going into that specific step. So what
do you get in here? You get like the
messages, the context, the model that
you're using, the step number and any of
the like the steps data, what has
happened. Um and then in here you can
literally return any of those top level
parameters. So you could return a
completely different message state for
like if uh let's say if step number
step step number or is greater than 20
you could basically take in just where
is it? These are the messages that are
actively and running. You could say
messages slice and take just the last
five. And so in this way you now have
running at the beginning of every single
step you've got this sliding filter that
is only taking the most recent five
messages.
Now this is a very interesting like long
rabbit hole that we can go down because
I've been thinking about this a lot. Uh,
I was telling Casper before like I I've
been working on a coding agent for a few
months now that I have it like yesterday
it ran for uh I wonder if I can find the
exact photo but like it ran for 104
minutes in in one single turn. Uh let's
see if we have the exact
so I can prove to you these are all my
I think it was right here. Yeah. 104
minutes it ran for used 316 tool calls
changed 29 files and it used only 32% of
GPT54's
um context window. I have zero
compaction running on this. And I think
this is like kind of a hot take today
because everyone's got like their own
systems where they're I I previously had
I was stripping away tool calls that
were earlier on in the message history
when I hit a certain threshold so that I
would stay between 40% and 60% of the
token window or the context window. Um,
but you have a really big problem that
comes up when you do that, which is you
invalidate the the input cache every
single time you do that. Um, which I
think is like it's is it's like a oh
Yeah. Like of course. Um, but
it was important when the token windows
I think were like 400k. So when I when I
was first building this main models I
was using was Opus with I think the 400k
token window and GPT53 codeex both 400k
token windows and so you would hit that
40% pretty quickly but with these
million token windows
I'm not seeing as much of an issue. So
what I'm building instead for it is more
of the are two things. one uh more
comprehensive
like I have sub agents implemented here
and we can talk about that a lot as well
like taking dedicated pieces of work
that can be somewhat independent and
putting them off of the main context
thread and then like returning just a
thousand tokens which is the summary of
whatever the objective was and bringing
that back in. So that's just like
efficient use of the context window in a
session. Um but also having like a
dedicated tool. Uh the AMP the folks at
AMP did a really cool implementation of
this is giving the agent a handoff tool
which at a certain point agent can call
generate some kind of context that it
wants to pass into a fully new
thread and that is that becomes like the
main thread to start off with. And so I
I feel as as much as you can push into
sub agent territory is the because these
uh summarization this compaction by
agent summariz or by LLM summarization
is lossy. Like you saw the there was the
the infamous Twitter thread of I think
the head of one of the heads of AI at at
Meta AI who let her who asked her open
claw like can you archive like emails
from yesterday and it just deleted her
entire inbox and she was like asking
telling it to stop and it was like no
you asked me to do this I'm going to
keep going and the reason why was
because there were so many emails that
were brought in by an inefficient tool.
Put that in. That triggered
autocompaction
and the emails overwhelmed her initial
instructions. And so her initial
instruction that was don't do this was
gone. And so like that's what scares me
a lot about like I don't have a great
system. Whether you just keep the user
messages and strip out everything else.
I don't know. But that's my long tangent
here. I can go into that a little bit
more. My whole point here trying to say
is like I don't think having having used
this my coding agent for 14 hours a day
for every single piece of work that I've
done in the last four months compaction
has not been an issue to me. Um
and I like I I was showing you earlier I
have a 95% uh cache token read ratio on
on that as well. And that to me is like
more valuable both in terms of like
speed, performance and and cost. But
that long- winded very long- winded uh
rabbit hole for that and we can go into
that more as well. But this is this is
like this is how you would manipulate
context between steps. And the last
thing I'll mention here is like a lot of
we were very um intentional with this
API being functional, right? like this
is a function that runs on every single
step rather than like returning a uh a
new message array here and persisting
that to the steps afterwards. Like this
is very easy to reason about because
this is a blank like an empty function
that starts at every single invocation.
Your messages coming in here are the
aggregated set of messages throughout.
And it also gives you like when you do
persist at the very end, you know that
you're getting like the full message
history at the end. Sorry. Was that
helpful?
>> Cool. All right. Um, and this is good as
well because I know I'm kind of doing
kind of basic stuff and you guys have
already used it. So, please do stop me
with interesting questions like that.
I'm happy to to blabber. Um, so we're
going to do we're getting to the fun
part now. We have I think we installed
the beta, right? Uh no, we didn't. So,
we're going to go through and we're
going to run this command pmppm add
versel sandbox at beta.
And then um we are going to create a new
lib file
called sandbox.ts.
And like I was explaining before with
these um persistent sandboxes, we're
just going to create a function
leverages this functionality. So we pass
in a name and then it's going to check
if that sandbox exists. If it does, it
will return that. Otherwise, it will
create it and return that sandbox
instance.
Uh so we've got that set up.
Now this is some new stuff that I don't
think any of you would seen if you
haven't used uh AISK6 before. So we've
been using the tool loop agent and we've
been calling it just like this pass in
our agent pass in our messages but very
rarely is your is the only thing dynamic
in your agent your context like a lot of
the time there is different there are
different structured inputs that should
be changing the way that your agent
behaves a lot of the time like the
classic I give here if you have a
customer support agent one of the
classic things that you'll want coming
into that is like the customer ID and
like maybe their their um what do you
call the customer type whether they're
enterprise or hobby for example with
Verscell and then the behavior of that
model might change based on that if
you're running a system for hundreds of
thousands of people maybe you're an
airline I think you're you're in travel
right or no
>> construction
>> construction so tra travel works we
we'll use that for now Imagine you're
British Airways and you've got a chat
bot and you are serving hundreds of
thousands of customers every day with
your chatbot and maybe a blue member
who's like the bottom of the thing, you
want to give them GPT54 mini. But for
gold member, you want to give them GPT54
Pro or something like that. These are
like structured inputs that
fundamentally alter and augment the
behavior. And the way that we used to do
that before is like functional style.
you'd say con create agent and you'd
have some kind of input that would
change you'd have your input here that
would ultimately like change the
behavior and you're doing if statements
and all that kind of stuff and so we saw
that and thought like these are uh it's
frustrated some people online which I
didn't realize it would these are call
options they change the way that they're
options that you pass at call time that
change the way that the model um behaves
And uh so the way that you can define
those is with a call option schema that
you pass in to your agent definition. So
I'm going to copy over all of this code
right here. And I may strip away some of
it so it's just easier to to see. So
we'll maybe we'll close this off and
focus just on the call option schema. So
what we want for our agent that is going
to be like this agent with a computer is
it should take in a sandbox in each
invocation right and the agent is going
to interact with that sandbox. So we
define a zod object for our call options
expected um and it's going to be an
instance of our sandbox class from the
versel sandbox.
We can then pass in that call option
schema into our tool loop agent
definition.
And if we were to go to our route, you
can see in our create agent UI stream
response, there is an options key. And
in there, we now have this type safe uh
options object that we need to pass in.
You can see we've got an error here. Our
options expect a sandbox.
>> Howdy.
>> No worries. I didn't know you have.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so we have our call option schema. Now
we like we actually need to do something
with our call options. And what we're
going to do here, we're going to, this
isn't going to make a ton of sense right
now, but it will as we go into it. We
want to have our sandbox available
within our agent runtime for any tool to
use. And the way that we're going to do
it is with a kind of loaded term here is
something called context with the uh
within the AI SDK agent runtime. And
what the context is is this is more
similar to React context than it is
agent context. And so if you're familiar
with React context, you have a provider
and any component within that nested uh
component tree can access random
arbitrary values within that. And so
this is the same idea is that you can
pass in any kind of arbitrary
data, variables, functions, whatever
they might be into this object and then
you can access it in your tool runtime
in your tool execute functions. So what
we're doing here is we're saying our
agent now expects a sandbox to come in
every single time it's used. And then
the first time it's called this prepare
call function will run. It runs only
once the first time that our agent is
called. And then it's going to take that
sandbox off of the call options and
inject it into our runtime context. This
runtime state that you have across agent
invocations.
Sorry, not across agent implications
across the entire agent run within
across steps. So that's that's the big
thing. Um and I know this this is this
is a lot right now. We we'll see it in a
second. It will make a lot more sense.
Um because we are going to define our
first tool.
So we're going to define a tool uh
called in a file called tools.tcs
and this is going to be a bash tool. Now
we feel very strongly that bash is all
you need. In a lot of cases these agents
are really really good at writing bash
commands. And so uh we actually for this
whole session are going to have just
this one tool bash that is going to do
everything for us. So how do you define
a tool with a SDK? You guys have all
used ASK before but there are three
components. Description super important
like can't overstate it enough. This is
what the model uses to decide whether to
use your tool and can also influence how
it uses your tool. Then input schema
obviously this is what that tool needs
in order to run. And then we have the
execute function and this is the code
that will be executed every single time
the agent uses it. And so now you'll see
where the context comes in. This is an
argument on the second u the second
argument of the execute function that
you can pull off in your tool runtime
access any of that um any of that
runtime state and then run commands. So
this is that cool way of your tool is
effectively
like uh wholly independent from the
agent it's interacting with but expects
this input to come in u and then can can
use it. And we have a cool update coming
to AISDK7 which actually adds typing for
the context and it types the main uh
context on the top level agent. So if
you were to pull in a a tool that
expects some kind of context, that will
then throw an error in your agent
definition for saying like you need to
provide this, which is really cool. Um,
and directly as a result of me pestering
Lars for three months as I've been using
this pattern a ton. Um, but so what we
have under the scenes is like we're
literally just pulling off the sandbox
from the context, running our bash
command that the agent generated, and
then returning the standard out any
errors, um, and then the exit code. So
we could jump back and head back to our
agent, which I don't think is running.
So we'll run PND dev
and we could say like run ls run ls-la.
Nope.
Why aren't we? Oh, see it's not working.
Uh because we haven't provided the
sandbox, of course. Um if I followed
instructions, I would have known that.
Uh the next step, which is well, there
are two steps that are quite important.
One, we need to actually give our I was
going way ahead of myself. We need to
give um our tool to our agent. So, we're
going to head back to our agent
definition. I'm just going to replace it
all. And you'll see that now on line 21,
we are passing in our bash tool that we
just created. And then most importantly,
we actually need to update our route
handler to get said sandbox and pass it
in to the agent run. And so we're going
to do that with our uh helper function
that we created before. Create or get
sandbox specifying a sandbox name. So
this is the this is just a random ID in
an application. You'd have these names
tied probably to a user's name or to a
session. Um and that becomes this
persistent sandbox that you can use
across invocations. Uh so we get our
sandbox here you can see and then we
pass it in to our call options. You see
again if you didn't pass this in we
would get an error because it's uh end
to end type safe and who doesn't love
endtoend type safety?
So the final thing that we're going to
want to do uh you can it will work right
now but you obviously need to wait and
you don't see the terminal actually like
the the commands running in line. So we
can actually define a component for our
bash tool which we'll do uh here by
providing a case for tool-bash.
So I'm going to jump to back to the
page. I'm going to copy this in and we
can look at this again. So before we had
we have what should be rendered if the
model generates a text um or model or
the user has some text. What should be
rendered in the UI if the model uses web
search? And then finally what should be
rendered in the UI if the model uses
bash. Uh and this obviously I didn't
create because it both looks good and um
and it works. So we can say run ls-la.
And now we should see our terminal
that's spun up. It's running the command
and we'll see returned that we are in a
versail sandbox.
So this is like uh I know this is kind
of a small this is a small leap for us
today but a huge jump for our agent to
be able to now have this. Uh but you'll
notice and I go back to instructions and
behavior. If I said, "What do you see?"
Agent is like oblivious. It now knows
that it's got a bash tool, but it
doesn't really know when to use it, how
to use it, what to use. Um, and so this
is when we could literally say, we could
jump into our agents instructions here
and say, you are an agent with a
computer. You can access with bash. If
the user asks what you can see, use ls
something like that. This is ter
terrible system prompt, but you can be
like, what do you see? Naturally, like
it's going to start using the computer a
little bit more. Um, this is not hugely
helpful right now. I think a natural
progression to having access to a file
system is like let's store in it, right?
Um, and the pretty natural next step for
storing things with an agent is memory.
I think a lot of people are thinking
about what's the ideal memory. And my
hot take here is that memory is a file
that you store in your sandbox and you
have some kind of actual deterministic
code for pulling that in, injecting it
into the system prompt and then
potentially having some kind of
structure in your file system for
different memory types. So you'll have
like a core memories.mmd which is the
stuff that gets sent in every single
term and in there are probably some
information like for uh to search
conversation history. It's stored in
conversations.jsonl
or something like that. But the point
being the file system becomes this
playground this environment for you to
store in a structured way a lot of this
information. And the beauty here is that
these agents are so good at generating
bash commands that they can use things
like find, like ls, like gp, like glob,
all of these kinds of things. Um, so
we're gonna, our final thing that we're
going to play around with here is adding
this concept of persistent memory. So,
uh, I'm going to copy this in quickly in
here.
I I explained the basic idea of what I
was thinking about which is like let's
have a file in our file system called
memories.mmd.
Uh the agent will know to put new
memories inside there and then we'll
actually in that prepare call which runs
once before every single agent run.
Let's fetch that file and just inject it
into the system prompt into the
instructions with some kind of context
around it. So that's what I'm doing
here. I'm fetching the memories MD. I'm
getting the the string itself and then I
have the instructions from before.
You're a coding agent with access to a
computer. You have a memories.mmd file
that you can read and write to. You
should always add any facts the user
shares to memories.mmd. And then if we
have any memories here are your
memories. Otherwise, no memories yet.
And we could even ask something like no,
actually that's fine. We can go like
this. And so now I could say, hey, my
name is Nico. Again, really kind of dumb
dumb examples here, but we'll see the
the beginning of it. User's name is
Nico. And now, if I refresh and I say
hi,
we'll see that it's doing some behavior
that we don't want, which is it's adding
some kind of arbitrary like user greeted
with hi
that. But you can see that it did
regardless like it had Nico in the file
system. And I could say something here
like uh don't report every
only record important memories.
>> You're you're absolutely right.
>> Important facts the user shares only
record important memories. Let's try.
You see this this explains what's broken
with most agents is that like me even as
a native English speaker kind of uh
writes conflicting instructions that an
agent will obviously take very
literally. So I say hi and now hopefully
it's done it again. So so you see like
this is so much of this this is also
like a kind of a dumber model uh with or
no we moved up to GPT54. So, it's not
even uh I would say don't
don't share greetings. And this is bad
because you obviously this is like the
per the pink elephant. You don't really
want to mention behavior you don't want
it to do because it's now activating
parameters and we don't really know what
it's doing. But let's
uh let's see.
man
really. Uh so that doesn't Yeah,
exactly. The fact that
nuke my memories. Uh, so let let's get
rid of
delete them.
Okay, great. Let's remove the So now, I
mean, this is the this is kind of the
fun part of building this is like we're
we're literally trying to get this kind
of machine to use this persistent state.
And you'll see that I I find this so
having built so much with sandboxes now
the fact that we just have that ID that
name and it's just persisting whether
it's alive or whether it's actively
running or not but we have that
persistent state is really cool. I did
work on some prompts before that do make
the memory system better. So you could
see do not save trivial interactions
like greeting small talk or information
that can be derived from the codebase
itself. So we're going to copy this over
and see how this does. Um, and now
hopefully when we go hi, I've also made
this added system prompts here to make
it a little bit more inquisitive. So, a
bit like open clause like onboarding was
like what's your name? Do you do so like
hi I'm Nico. Um, and so now it's adding
users name. What do you do? I work on
why am I doing this? I work on the AI
SDK at Verscell. I don't know why I was
typing so much today. Uh, so then we get
that added and now when I pop in to a
new chat, hi. Like we've got that memory
that's persisted over these states. Now
another really cool thing that you can
start doing just by leveraging the bash
that we have here is
using something we already have in the
environment and something the agent is
already very good at which is generating
code and executing code. And so a
classic thing that you'll see which is I
think is why open cloud was so exciting
and why agents have really taken off
this year is this idea of agents
modifying or extending themselves and a
big part of that is less about modifying
itself but it's about like creating
these giving it the feedback loop in the
environment where it can build run code
evaluate the output and uh and iterate
on that and I think that's also why
coding has become naturally like the
first place this has really gone crazy
is like we've got compilers, we've got
type checkers. It's like it is the
perfect environment for that uh
basically ripple uh loop. Um, but so
I've added another kind of thing here
that telling the agent if there are any
repeatable tasks like make a Python
script out of it and then inject those
Python scripts into or the description
of it into the end of our memories MD
and use that as like a core or or use
that to decide what to do next. So if
the user asks you to get the weather,
make a weather script. And if the user
asks to get the weather again, use that
script that you already have access to.
And this is like these are the building
blocks of this agent that learns that
builds what builds on itself as we go.
And so we can give this a go. We can see
how it will do. Um we say get the
weather in London. Uh use Python. I
mean, this is a I'm going to force it a
little bit here given we're doing a
demo. Uh, and we'll see what it does.
So, it's going to write some Python here
and we'll see it's it's gotten the
weather and now it's added that to our
our memories MD
and it's pretty cool. Like, this was all
one assistant turn just using bash and
now it's got this tool for for getting
the weather. So now we could see get
weather NSF.
Let's try. Will it work? And look, it
used it used it is not minus 11 uh
because it got Quebec Canada for some
reason. We'll have to modify it uh
slightly.
Yes. Do this.
Do this. Oops. I probably broke
everything here. Um, amazing. It
actually worked. Okay, so it's 12
degrees Celsius. But you can see now
like we've got this um I prefer. See,
it's cool. Like the more that it's
asking, the more that it's building
itself, the more that it's learning
about what I like. And now in this
computer, this is like my agent's
dedicated playground and workspace for
it to help me out with anything. So that
was the basis for what I wanted to go
through today. Okay. What I did want to
show you is like what you can I've I've
built a very complex agent system on top
of these exact patterns that I use now
every single day to get my work done. Um
so I wanted to I mean shill this is
coming out later today. I'm holding
myself to that. And this is effectively
like uh cursor background agents uh but
using those concepts that we had today.
uses AI SDK, uses that exact pattern, um
uses um AI gateway for inference, uses
workflow, so it can run infinitely and
each of the steps are durable. So each
LLM step is matched to a durable
workflow step and if any step fails, it
literally retries until it gets um it
gets a result. Um,
and yeah, this also builds on that uh
what we were talking about before with
sub agents. So like I can create any new
session um and be like, "Yeah, we have
to finish. I'm done anyway. This is more
me showing off." But um spin up a uh sub
agent to explore this project
and um after it creates because this is
on my hotspot so it's a little bit slow.
kind of see effectively what I'm trying
to show is like this this uh pattern
scales to a pretty large system uh and
to show you like this is being used by
uh so yeah we've got sub agent spinning
up um and this runs in the background
like this is being used by 23 people at
versell I've put three and a half 3.8 8
billion tokens through this uh in the
last like month or two. That cash read
ratio I was telling you I'm very proud
of. 90 91%
uh responsible for
close to 350 PRs although this doesn't
include all of them that closed. Um,
and yeah, and you'll see like this will,
if we go back here, has resumable
streams, and our, you can see our sub
agent was going off finding, searching
all of this stuff off of the main
thread, use 30,000 tokens, but just
returned like 500 at the very end. So
that keeps us within literally 7,000
tokens for the main like agent thread.
So yeah,
and this hopefully will be out later
today.
I'm obviously here if you guys have
questions after if we're getting kicked
out. Um, yeah.